So far we've only talked about how to
use Gradle to build a project component
of a single deliverable output.
But builds rarely stay so simple.
A Gradle project can have
any number of sub projects,
each of which also has
their own sub projects.
Every multi project build
also has a root project.
Even if that root project is
the container for its subprojects.
You'll generally create a subproject
in order to move some reusable
functionality into a library.
That way the library can be used
by other projects, and also so
Gradle can determine
that the library and
the app that depends on it
should be built together.
A Gradle multi-project build is
configured in a settings decorative file
in the root of your project.
If you're creating an Android app,
using Android Studio this file's
automatically generated for you.
In fact, every Android project
created by Android Studio
is a Gradle multi project by default.
Note, Android Studio refers to
sub projects as modules, but
we'll use the two terms interchangeably.
let's check out an example.